okay Rob your front points if your
crampons are your main weight-bearing
things good lord
comedian Rob Riggle and I are in a race
against time searching to find a cache
of supplies before nightfall but first
we've got to scale this mountain of ice
so you're watching the flat rope so
we're not kicking into that that's a
long way down looking you're this it's
only like a journey you're fully for ice
climb that's what's behind Rob it's a
150-foot deep crevasse that I can see
below take your time it's good
no hurry okay con Rob's was a one lesson
you learn from basic training slow and
steady wins the race
never quit okay that is you never quit
looking really good pretty strong the
last bit
[Music]
okay keep using your points now you can
stand up a bit more is just about going
ah it's a good climb it's a great motor
it's a great motivator having a 150 foot
crevasse right behind you that kind of
gets you up the knot the hill crossing
these things is always hard works it's
like you know 200 meters in a straight
line two hours well done they thanks
he's panting he's sweating he's done
well we're at the top
[Music]